hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrol
ac.l2-3.1.21 that should never asked for
the description of this video what
control I was going to talk about
well okay all right limit the use of
organizational portable storage devices
on external systems yes sir that's what
we're going to talk about
[Music]
all right so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
of this cmmc dfars and this sp171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it so cmfc control
ac.l1-3.1.21 limit the use of
organizational portable storage devices
on external systems what are they
talking about well here's what they're
talking about what they're doing
is there mandating that you have control
over portable storage devices your thumb
drives portable hard drives Etc so that
ultimately at the end of the day it's
understood that the less these devices
are used outside of the secure network
and then brought back in the less risk
you have to your network and data they
really want you to be in control of
these so that you limit the risk uh
which is so core to nist SP 10171
remember at the core of it NIS purpose
is to protect data and and have
information security but the methodology
is all about risk management kind of a
really cool fact a really cool lens of
how to look at it and of course when it
comes to cmmc it's really just
third-party assessment of nist SP 800
171 let's check out what the assessors
are looking for how to make them happy
on this one so uh if we look there's
three assessment points here number one
we want to determine if the use of
portable storage devices containing cui
on external systems is identified and
documented okay where do you get a look
well if we're giving a sample answer I'd
probably say something like the
organization inhibits the use of
portable storage media on external
systems per the it use and cyber
security policy hey knock knock you got
an itu's policy right
sure you do
time to call on call yeah it's the time
to give us a call all right now
assessment Point number two determine if
limits on the use of portable storage
devices containing cui on external
systems are defined the organization
prohibits the use of portable storage
media on external systems per the it use
and cyber security policy yes
yes there's that policy thing again you
know there's some controls you talk
about in these videos we're like hey
look you got to be prepared to
demonstrate that to an assessor this one
there's probably a little bit of
demonstration you can do but the reality
is you really need to be prepared to
ante up and show them your documentation
if you don't have documentation one of
the coolest things we do for our clients
is we always deliver a complete set of
totally done-for-you documentation all
right this is like literally six figures
worth of attorney time that went into
all of these policies there's a ton of
them and then you know you factor in our
time as far as you know some pretty
Advanced I.T people and cyber security
and compliance people all right there's
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of legalese that went into the policies
that we customize for our clients so I
know a lot of our clients come to us
because they're just like trying
desperately to figure out what in the
world to do about their complete and
total lack of policy creation we can
literally kick start you into compliance
in terms of I can't guarantee that I can
make you compliant I have to be very
careful I got a CMC code ethics but uh I
will say again we can kick start you to
have a full set of documentation and by
the time we're done working with you and
understanding you then at that point we
you know we have that documentation
fully customized and again it's it's
what's required to meet compliance now
third assessment point now that I'm done
being all careful and disclaiming is
determine if the use of portable storage
devices containing cui on external
systems is limited as defined
limited as defined huh I guess that
would mean we'd have to Define it
somewhere where do we do that well again
let's go back to our sample answer right
the organization prohibits the use of
portable storage media on external
systems per the itu since cyber security
policy now here's the thing with that
right we're going to do it through
policy because again in our sample
answer that's how it's done however
you've been in a lot of other places
right we got Group Policy we could
actually use Group Policy to force limit
the use of portable storage device we
could block USB ports we can do a lot of
stuff on this control a lot of different
ways that we can actually Define how
we're limiting portable storage devices
in our systems now if you're banging
your head against the wall going like
all right the good news is hey an
on-call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this D fars
nist itar and cmmc compliance stuff
dropped in their lap like a seagull on a
sunny day you know what it's like it
kind of sucks we teach you how to level
up and be a proper on-call compliance
hero for your company eliminating gaps
gray areas and getting this solved all
while showing you how to leverage
compliance as your secret weapon to land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins now that's what becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmccomplianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now
and if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better Hulk smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerds
roll it out until the next compliance
tip my friends stay safe and secure out
there and hit us in the comments below
to let us know what you'd like to know
more about when it comes to information
security and compliance and be careful
where you insert that portable storage
media of yours okay stay safe I'll see
you on the next one
[Music]
all right